Au moment où vous verrez cette vidéo
je serai arrivé à Lausanne en Suisse
où je joue ce soir, techniquement c'est ce soir pour vous, demain et je repars dimanche
J'y ai pas mal de choses de calées dont un meet up
alors en prévision je vais tourner 3 vidéos d'avance
si durant les prochains jours
vous me voyez dans la même position avec la même lumière
c'est que j'ai mis les 3 vidéos
et sinon j'essayerai de tourner là bas
mais je ne sais jamais comment ça se passe
La dernière fois que je suis parti en tournée, il n'y avait pas de wifi
je ne pouvais pas publier c'était une catastrophe
J'ai dû la télécharger en 3G
du coup la vidéo avait 1h30 de retard.
Donc je vais être prévoyant.
Et aujourd'hui je me transforme en BookTube, puisque je vais vous parler d'un livre
qui va vous intéresser. C'est pas un placement de produit
Je l'ai acheté avec mes petits sous, j'ai envie d'en parler
parce qu'il est extrêmement bien
C'est le livre de...
*Générique*
Ce n'est pas le livre de générique, évidemment,
c'est le livre d'un certain William alias Doc Seven
Il a sorti le Tour du Monde des infos insolites
car la curiosité n'est pas un vilain défaut!
et je me suis demandé ce que ça pouvait donner Doc Seven en livre
J'aime beaucoup ces vidéos, je regarde ce qu'il fait depuis longtemps. J'aime bien
Et tout son schéma d'apprentissage marche aussi avec l'image
D'apprentissage et de découverte
Donc naturellement je me suis demandé si on pouvait transposer ça en livre
Alors, il a sorti un peu sous forme de carnet de voyage
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les bords sont arrondis
avec un petit vernis sélectif
je crois d'ailleurs que ça avait été la même chose
Voilà c'est ça, pour les questions cons qui avait le vernis sélectif pareil
qui est un très bon bouquin aussi.
Mais je vais parler plutôt de celui de William, plutôt que de celui d'Hugo qui est très bien, mais
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
Déjà j'aime bien le livre soit hors collection
c'est à dire que tout le livre a été créé pour lui, ça se sent, ça se voit
Il y a toutes les illustrations qui sont superbes
Comme dans les vidéos il a gardé le principe des 7
donc ça va de 7 fruits méconnus à 7 objets cultes des années 2000 à 7 trésors introuvables
Il y a certaines choses qu'on a déjà découvert dans ces vidéos mais qui sont, on va dire, enrichies
franchement moi qui connait bien la chaîne
La plupart des choses sont inédites
Le livre commence par une petite préface, elle est très courte
ça sera surement mon reproche, en fait.
J’espérais dans le livre en savoir un peu plus, posément,
sur Doc Seven. J'aurai bien aimé le lire un peu plus longuement sur la démarche de faire le livre
et la démarche de nous pousser à faire découvrir des choses en les catégorisant
Après c'est aussi un goût personnel quand j'ouvre un livre, j'aime lire les...
les préfaces, j'aime lire les post faces aussi
J'aime lire ce qui n'a aucun rapport avec le livre
comme dans les vidéos il catégorise de 7 à 1
donc 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1
et après il y a pas de règle.
Tout dépend du contenu il a pas écrit pour écrire
En général, ça tient sur 2 pages et des fois plus 3, 4 voir 5 pages
Quand je lisais j'avais la voix de Doc Seven en tête
Donc ça c'était assez marrant de voir que tu es tellement imprégné
que quand tu lis le livre, tu l'entends en fait.
Tu entends son rythme,
et comme il y a mis sa manière de parler, des traits d'humour, des choses comme ça
et bien on récupère tout le ton enrichi de ce qu'il fait sur YouTube
Et ça se retrouve vraiment à la lecture puisqu'on a des points d’exclamations  un peu partout
des choses entre parenthèse
donc ça participe quand on subvocalise à bien entendre sa manière de parler
Alors "subvocaliser" pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce que ça veut dire c'est quand on lit dans sa tête, quand on s'entend parler en lisant
on en avait parlé dans la vidéo sur la lecture rapide, que je vous invite à découvrir si vous ne l'avez pas vu. Je vais vous mettre une fiche ici
Ça se lit bien, ça s’emmène partout.
Je trouve ça cool les YouTubers qui font des livres,
à chaque fois j'y prends vraiment du plaisir à pouvoir les mettre dans un sac et de pouvoir les lire dans les transports en commun ou ailleurs
C'est une autre manière de les rencontrer. C'est cool
Il y a 60 choses différentes qui sont traitées dans le livre
Je veux dire c'est par rien. C'est pas je sors un livre pour sortir un livre
il y a un vrai contenu
en majeur parti inédie
avec plus de 60 sujets
Tu sais qu'il y a des mois de boulot derrière
et comme j'ai tendance à bien aimer tout ce qui goodies, ou choses un peu exclusives etc...
Le fait d'avoir ça en objet sous forme d'objet, avoir un livre quelques choses que je peux avoir chez moi et ranger
Je trouve ça vraiment cool
Je vous le dis dans les autres livres dans le même style, j'avais vraiment bien aimé celui des questions cons
et celui de Bruce de la chaîne E-penser, j'ai pas encore lu le 2
mais le premier était excellent
Il est pas là, il doit être dans ma chambre celui ci
Voilà vidéo différente, j'avais envie de vous parler de ce livre
parce que ça change un peu, parce qu'on fait ce qu'on veut
des fois je faisais des hors sujet sur la chaîne, c'était un hors sujet
et pas tant que ça parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de choses à apprendre
et à découvrir dans le bouquin, donc c'est cool
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu. Si c'est la 1ère fois que vous êtes sur la chaîne
ou déjà quelques fois, mais que, vous n'aviez pas encore pris le temps n'hésitez pas à ...
vous abonnez également et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 11h, le samedi c'est 11h
Tchao !